>> Laura: JOE BIDEN HAS PUT
OUT A COMMERCIAL TRYING TO TURN
THE TABLES ON YOU ON THE
QUESTION OF FOOTBALL.
LET’S WATCH IT.
>> GOOD WEATHER BY OPENING DAY.
WE ARE GOING TO BE IN THE 60s.
ENJOY THE GAME.
AND NOW, PLEASE JOIN IN THE
SINGING OF OUR NATIONAL ANTHEM.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: WHY IS FOOTBALL SO
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY WITH THE
BIG TEN, ALL THESE MOMS,
PLAYERS.
THEY WANT TO PLAY.
ARE THEY SAFER PLAYING THAN NOT?
>> President Trump: IT SHOWS
YOU THE LIE OF THE DEMOCRATS.
I’M THE ONE WHO SAYS PLAY
FOOTBALL.
THEY ARE YOUNG, STRONG PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH COVID OR THE
CHINA VIRUS OR WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT.
I’M THE ONE.
THEY DIDN’T LIKE MY NARRATIVE SO
THEY MADE UP THE NARRATIVE.
IF YOU LOOK, MICHIGAN IS CLOSED.
ALL THE STATES THAT ARE CLOSED.
NORTH CAROLINA’S CLOSE.
THESE TAPES ARE CLOSED ARE RUN
BY DEMOCRATS.
THE REASON THEY ARE CLOSED IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ELECTION ON
NOVEMBER 3RD.
THEY DON’T WANT THE OPENING OF
THE STATES AND THEY DON’T WANT
THE INCOME.
THEY WANT TO KEEP IT NICE AND
CLOSE.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT, THE
STATES THAT ARE CLOSE, IT’S
TERRIBLE WHAT THEY’VE DONE.
YOU DISCUSS IT A LOT AND SO DO
I.
THERE’S A LOT OF DEATH,
DEPRESSION, DRUG ADDICTION ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
WHEN YOU KEEP IT CLOSE, I THINK
YOU’RE LOSING MORE PEOPLE THAN
-- IT’S TERRIBLE WHAT YOU’RE
DOING TO PEOPLE THAN WHEN YOU
OPEN IT.
SO I’M THE FOOTBALL GUY.
I’M THE ONE THAT WANTS TAP
FOOTBALL.
I PUT IT OUT ALL THE TIME.
I’M VERY UPSET WITH BIG TEN.
BIG TEN.
THEY SHOULD’VE OPENED IT.
I’M THE ONE THAT WANTS THE
FOOTBALL.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
THEY SAW IT AND THEY SAID
TRUMP --
THESE PEOPLE JUST --
>> Laura: THEY HAVE PLAYERS
SUING NOW TO PLAY ON THEIR
PARENTS ARE REALLY UPSET.
MICHIGAN STATE, PENN STATE,
MINNESOTA.
OHIO STATE.
COULD’VE BEEN THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONS THIS YEAR, OHIO STATE.
>> President Trump:
ABSOLUTELY.
A NUMBER OF THEM IN THAT
CATEGORY.
LOOK AT PENNSYLVANIA.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT
NORTH CAROLINA.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT MICHIGAN.
THEY ARE ALL DEMOCRATS.
THOSE ARE THE STATES.
I DO BELIEVE THE GOVERNORS ARE
TELLING THOSE COLLEGES WE DON’T
WANT IT.
>> Laura: THAT’S AN IMPORTANT
POINT FOR AMERICANS TO
UNDERSTAND.
YOU THINK THE GOVERNORS ARE
PUTTING THEIR FOOT DOWN AND
SAYING NO.
THE SEC, THEY ARE GOING TO TRY
TO PLAY.
ACC IS PLAYING.
WHEN YOU THINK IT’S POLITICAL,
MR. PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: THE
GOVERNOR OF PENNSYLVANIA, THE
GOVERNOR OF MICHIGAN, THE
GOVERNOR OF NORTH CAROLINA.
THEY CONTROL BOTH TEAMS DIRECTLY
OR INDIRECTLY.
SO MUCH MONEY, SO MUCH AID, SO
MANY OF THE THINGS INCLUDING
TRAFFIC SIGNS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT THEY HAVE TO GET.
THERE WAS GOVERNORS CONTROL
THOSE SCHOOLS.
THAT’S ALL DONE BY DEMOCRATS.
TO SHOW YOU HOW THEY LIE AND HOW
THEY CHEAT AND THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM YOU HAVE, I WANT
FOOTBALL BACK.
BY THE WAY, ARE YOU WATCHING?
I WANT FOOTBALL.
JOE BIDEN AS THEY CAN KNOW
FOOTBALL.
JOE BIDEN DOESN’T KNOW HE’S
ALIVE.
LET’S SEE HOW IT ALL TURNS OUT.
THE VERY SAD THING.
I WILL SAY THIS.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL.
WE CLOSED IT UP.
WE ARE OPENING AND APPEARED
WE’RE DOING RECORD NUMBERS.
AS YOU SAW OVER 9 MILLION PEOPLE
EMPLOYED NOW OVER THE LAST THREE
MONTHS, THAT’S A RECORD IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A CHANCE OF HAVING ONE
OF THE BEST YEARS WE’VE EVER HAD
NEXT YEAR.
UNLESS SOMEBODY COMES IN AND
WANTS TO READ YOUR TAXES, PUT
BACK REGULATIONS.
I’M NOT SURE.
I GAVE THE BIGGEST TAX DECREASE
IN THESE D OF OUR COUNTRY AND
WERE GOING DOWN LOWER.
I’M NOT SURE I THINK THE
REGULATION CUTS THAT I DID WHICH
WERE THE BIGGEST IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY MIGHT HAVE BEEN
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE TAX
CUTS.
>> Laura: YOU SAID JOE BIDEN
IS CHINA’S CANDIDATE TO WIN.
THEY WANT HIM BADLY.
HE SAID THE RNC SPEECH, YOU SAID
I KNOW IT BUT I’M NOT GOING TO
TELL YOU WHY.
WITHOUT COMPROMISING NATIONAL
SECURITY.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
IT.
>> President Trump: WALKING
AWAY WITH A BILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS.
JOE DOESN’T EVEN CRITICIZE
CHINA.
I’VE NEVER EVEN HEARD HIM
CRITICIZE CHINA.
HE WAS THE ONE IS THAT GIANT IS
WONDERFUL.
CHINA’S THIS AND THAT CHINA IS
NOT THE ENEMY AND THEY ARE NOT
THE PROBLEM.
I HAVE TAKEN BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS, TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OUT OF CHINA.
>> Laura: TAKING THE TARIFF
SOLVED, SURE.
>> President Trump: THE ARABS
ARE GOING TO COME OFF.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TARIFFS.
THAT WOULD DESTROY US BECAUSE IT
GIVES THEM AN UNFAIR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE.
WE ARE TAKING IN BILLIONS.
I GET ALONG VERY WELL WITH
PRESIDENT XI ALTHOUGH I MUST
TELL YOU SINCE THE COVID
SITUATION I’VE NOT EXACTLY BEEN
TALKING TO HIM TOO MUCH.
>> Laura: CAN YOU MAKE THEM
PAY FOR THEM?
>> President Trump: THEY ARE
PAYING A LOT NOW.
>> Laura: HOW COULD THEY PAY?
>> President Trump: IN TERMS
OF DEATH IN PEOPLE AND I’M NOT
TALKING ABOUT JUST US, YOU’RE
TALKING WITH THE WORLD.
WHAT THEY’VE DONE TO THIS
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
IN TERMS OF DEATH.
ECONOMICALLY AT SOME POINT MAYBE
YOU CAN CATCH UP.
BUT YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT A LOT
OF GOOD TRADE DEALS.
I MADE AN UNBELIEVABLE TRADE
DEAL.
THEY FRANKLY, THEY ORDERED MORE
CORN LAST WEEK THAN ANY TIME AT
ANY TIME IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: ARE THEY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PANDEMIC WITH
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO
HONG KONG, WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IN THE PHILIPPINES?
CHOKING OFF SOME OF THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA?
>> President Trump: I THINK
THEY ARE HURT MUCH WORSE THAN
PEOPLE THINK.
THEY ARE HAVING A VERY HARD TIME
IN CHINA.
CHINA’S GOING VERY BAD INSIDE,
THE REAL NUMBERS.
>> Laura: MANUFACTURING HAS
GOTTEN BACK TO PAR.
>> President Trump: IT’S NOT.
THEY ARE DOING POORLY.
CHINA IS DOING VERY POORLY AND
THEY LOST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE, MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
THEY JUST DON’T REPORT IT.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU KNOW
THAT?
>> President Trump: BY THE WAY
I SAW STATISTIC THE OTHER DAY
TALKING ABOUT ONLY 6% OF THE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY DIED FROM COVID
WHICH IS A VERY INTERESTING --
THAT THEY DIED FROM OTHER.
>> Laura: THEY HAD
COMORBIDITIES WHICH YOU HAVE
GOTTEN CRITICIZED FOR BECAUSE
THERE ARE COMORBIDITIES IN THE
ITALIAN SHOWED A 70 SOMETHING
PERCENT HAVE 32 COMORBIDITIES.
BUT COVID MIGHT’VE BEEN THE KEY
MORBIDITY BUT THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> President Trump: IT’S AN
INTERESTING STATISTIC.
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT, ARE
YOU STILL HAVING FUN DOING THIS?
>> President Trump: I’M HAVING
A GOOD TIME.
WE ARE DOING A JOB JUST ABOUT
NOBODY ELSE IS EVER DONE AND
NOBODY EVER CHALLENGES ME ON IT,
I’LL SAY IT AGAIN.
THIS ADMINISTRATION DESPITE ALL
THE FAKE RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA
AND HOAXES AND IMPEACHMENTS.
WE HAVE DONE MORE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAN ANY
PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
YOU LOOK AT OUR MILITARY IS
REBUILT.
IF YOU LOOK AT CHOICE FOR THE
VETS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE VETS AND
I PROTECTIVE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
WHICH BY THE WAY IF THEY GOT IN,
YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT IS GONE.
YOUR TAXES ARE TRIPLED.
YOUR RELIGIOUS LIBERTY FORGET
IT.
THEY ARE KEEPING THE CHURCH IS
CLOSED ON PURPOSE.
YOU HAVE CHURCHES THAT STILL
AREN’T OPEN BUT YOU’RE ALLOWED
TO GO TO A CASINO.
IT’S TERRIBLE.
>> Laura: A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON’T KNOW HOW FUNNY YOU ARE BUT
YOU’RE ONE OF THE FUNNIER PEOPLE
I KNOW BUT YOU’RE ALSO IN A VERY
SERIOUS TIME.
>> President Trump: IT IS VERY
SERIOUS.
IT’S NOT TIME FOR GAMES.
PEOPLE SAY HE COMES ACROSS AS A
LITTLE BIT ROUGH FOR A LITTLE
BIT DIRECT.
I DON’T HAVE TIME NOT TO BE.
I REALLY DON’T HAVE MUCH TIME
NOT TO BE.
WE HAVE TO GET THINGS DONE.
WE ARE GETTING THEM DOWN LIKE NO
PRESIDENT HAS EVER -- DESPITE
THE OBSTRUCTION.
THEY ARE UP STRUCTURES.
DESPITE THE TREMENDOUS
OBSTRUCTION.
WE ARE GETTING THEM DONE LIKE
NOBODY’S EVER DONE BEFORE AND